what's up guys and welcome to hari
sadhus the channel where we discussed
the latest tech news and delve into
newest tech parts today we are taking a
look at why the new a sick from bit main
which is designed to - theorem won't
really have an effect on the GPU market
and why this new release doesn't really
matter but first make sure to subscribe
to this channel if you haven't already
to be updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and PCs so why so sad
this machine is literally built to minor
theorem right and that should affect a
GPU mining because more people come and
buy this but that's not necessarily the
case is it because of the lack in
performance well this new machine is
actually expected to do 650 mega hashes
per second while only consuming 750
watts to put this in comparison
overclocked gtx 1080i
which said 100% power limit will only do
about 37 mega hashes per second yet
it'll consume 343 watts of power which
is almost half the power consumption
while not even 10 percent up the
performance so as you guys can see this
new ASIC is really gonna record in
performance so why is it not gonna
affect the GPU mining market is the
because of the price well I don't think
the price is the issue either because I
think we can safely assume that this new
ASIC is going to have much better
performance for the dollar compared to a
GPU because this is specifically built
for minor the real problem is the worth
of etherion if what your client mine is
worthless then what's the point of
mining it and that is kind of what we're
seeing with a theorem right now
cryptocurrency prices are heavily tied
to what society thinks a bit and how
hard it is to get that resource so as we
already know the crazy round crypto
currency mining is taking a huge hit and
it has been consistently dropping for a
while now also this new ASIC is going to
make mining a lot simpler
and if something's easier to get then
it's not gonna be worth as much and so
that's also going to be affecting the
price of a theorem first of all prices
of etherium have been going down
consistently and significantly for the
last few months and after this new ASIC
was revealed that decline has just been
accelerated that's right after this new
ASIC was revealed if your prices have
taken an even bigger hit for example
just seven days ago the price of a
theorem was 575 dollars about today it's
about only four hundred and fifty
dollars that's right it's over at $125
price drop and more than a 20% of loss
and this is not just a new trend this
trend has been going on for a long time
now for example just 30 days ago if
theorem was worth over eight hundred
dollars and as you can see it's almost
half of that and sixty days ago the
price of a theorem was almost three
times what it is right now so as you
guys can see the price of etherium have
been dropping significantly furthermore
the difficulty to mine of theorem has
been crazily increasing because there's
less of it and it's harder than mine
every single day and so difficulty has
been shooting up crazily and as you guys
can see the price are going down and the
difficulty is going up and so it really
doesn't make sense to invest in it
especially into an ASIC that can only
mine that and nothing else instead of a
GPU which is much more versatile so
evidently our GPU mining rig is still
much more versatile and probably a much
safer investment option but why exactly
as the review of this new ASIC led to
price drops of the theorem well the
price of cryptocurrency is also heavily
dependent on how hard it is to get
cryptocurrency
is a resource and it's just like money
or any other resource like gold for
example every day more and more gold
gets bought and there's less and less of
it and so the prices just keep
increasing but this new ASIC is making
mining much simpler especially for
aetherium
which is what in minds and as a result
though the price of it theorem is going
down because the theorem itself is
valued less because it's an easier
commodity to get so what about GPU
mining is that gonna keep going or is
that gonna die as well
well this trend can be seen on almost
all cryptocurrencies the difficulty just
keeps going up and the prices keeps
consistently going down so I believe
that GPU prices are gonna drop no matter
what this new ASIC does so that is why
this new ASIC doesn't really matter and
isn't really gonna affect the GPU market
or the price of GPU GPU price are going
to go down but it's not gonna be caused
by this it's just going to be caused by
a consistent downfall whether or not
this new ASIC is released you may be
like it's good to invest in something
that's low priced because it's probably
bound to go up while that statement may
be true for things like real estate
which will never really lose your value
because people always need land the
problem with this is that this is a
relatively new type of investment and as
a result it is really unknown what it's
going to do it could shoot up tomorrow
because some celebrity like publicize it
or it could just go and die next month
it all depends on what the public thinks
of it and the crazy surrounding it so as
a result no matter how seasoned of
investor or miner you are it's always
difficult to put more money in something
that's going down consistently and it's
not really known what's going to do next
so where exactly does it leave nvidia
and AMD well an analyst from wall street
so this guy is credible has lowered his
predictions for nvidia from $250 to $200
which is about a 7% loss and furthermore
his lowered his predictions for AMD from
$13 all the way to $7.50 which is over a
40% loss so as you guys can see nvidia
and AMD are going to be taking a huge
hit from less demand from minors while
this is not great news for Nvidia or AMD
it's great for people who have been
waiting to get a grab
his cards just at normal prices for
months and months so here's the gist of
what happened a new ASIC mining machine
designed specifically to mine Imperium
has recently been revealed and this has
created a lot of hype that GP price are
going to go down and that this is going
to have a huge impact
however cryptocurrency prices across the
board have been taking huge hits
recently and have been consistently
going down for many months now as a
result I believe that this new ASIC
won't really have that much of an effect
on the GPU market or GPU prices at the
same time however I do believe GPU
prices will go down but not caused by
the new ASIC it's actually just caused
by the consistent decrease in the
cryptocurrency prices and thus lost
demand for GPUs from miners at the end
this is leading to much less revenue and
as a result stock prices for Andean and
NVIDIA however there's a great use for
gamers who have been waiting to get
graphics cards for many months right now
but that's all I have for you guys this
time make sure to post what you guys
think about it in the comments down
below for example do you guys think that
money will make a debut again at the end
of this year or even point 19 or do you
hope that mining never comes back to
life make sure to post what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure to drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this one
but that's what I have for you guys who
started and until next time bye
[Music]